انشاهاري لاسرار ومواقف ومشاعر افراد
عائلته عند وفاته والدته الاميره ديانا
يروي عطش اسئله ربما راودت الكثير من
الناس حول تفاصيل وفاه الاميره الراحله
لكنه اثار في الوقت نفسه فضولا اكبر
لمتابعه ردود فعل الناس والقصر حول ما
يفرغه هاري من مشاعره مكبوته
[موسيقى]
فمن لا يذكر لقطات الامير هاري واخيه
ويليام بعد وفاته والدته ومشاعر التعاطف
مع الاميرين الصغيرين من قبل الملايين ممن
تابعه جنازه الاميره ديانا تسال الجميع
وقتها ماذا يدور في بال الاميرين لاول مره
يكشف الامير عن المشاعر ذلك اليوم خلف
الابتسامه ومصافحه الناس هاريه يقول انهما
اجبر على كابتن مشاعرهما مؤكدا انه لم
يبكي والدته سوى مره واحده يوم وفاتها همم
نفتي تاون
[موسيقى]
الذي يطرح في الاسواق ب 16 لغه مختلفه
سبقته ايام من تسريبات كشفت تفاصيل غير
متوقعه اقلقت العديد في القصر وخارجه حيث
تعتبر تصريح هاري مثلا عن مشاركته في قتل
25 عنصر من حركه طالبان تصريحا غير مدروس
كما اعتبر تصريحه حول استخدام المواد
المخدره تصريحا غير لائق لامير فيما اعتبر
الكثيرون ان تصريحاته لا رجعه عنها فيما
يخص ترميم العلاقه مع عائلته
هاري وتصريحاتهما حديث الشارع هنا في
بريطانيا مقابلات التلفزيونيه اللاذعه
وقاسيه على افراد العائله الملكيه تزامنا
مع اطلاق كتاب يتصدر لائحه اكثر الكتب
طلبا حول العالم ولكن مع افصاح هاري لكل
ما في قلبه هل يوجد المزيد هل ياخذ هاري
استراحه بعد اطلاق الكتاب وانتهاء التسويق
له لصباح العربيه من لندن عروب عبد الحق